saviez-vous que Telus et Kudo permettent
à d'autres entreprises de facturer des
services directement sur la facture
cellulaire de leurs abonnés vous allez
voir que ça fait bien d'aimer content
comme 85% de la population canadienne
Annick chican possède un cellulaire mon
téléphone pour moi c'est un petit
travail on partage on communique avec
nos enfants souvent dans le jour de j'ai
envoyé des textos à mes enfants peuvent
me contacter n'importe quand pour les
quatre cellulaires de sa famille Annick
a choisi coup d’eau une filiale de TELUS
elle est une fidèle cliente de ce
fournisseur de services mobile depuis
déjà 12 ans ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on était avec Kudo prend manque au
départ de c'était pour des prix puis
après on a juste continué avec eux
mais une mauvaise surprise apparaît sur
sa facture
on s'est rendu compte que moi j'avais un
frais supplémentaire sur ma ligne de
13,99 on savait pas c'était quoi puis on
a contacté coup d'eau ils nous ont dit
vous avez reçu un texto pour vous
informer que vous étiez abonné à ça
Annick fait des recherches et découvre
un texto qu'il n'a jamais ouvert en
fiche sur ce message de 53 87 donc c'est
même pas le nom d'une compagnie c'est
même pas un numéro de téléphone je
n'avais jamais pris connaissance parce
que justement c'est un message de
quelqu'un que je connais pas avec un
lien que je connais pas Annick a suivi
un conseil de base en sécurité
informatique celui de ne pas ouvrir un
message d'un numéro inconnu mais le
piège c'est justement de pas d'avoir
ouvert dans ce texto on lui annonce
qu'elle est abonné à un nouveau service
le message qu'on a reçu cette disait
allez voir nos nouveaux jeux maintenant
vous êtes abonnés au montant de 1399 par
mois 13,99 par mois pour un abonnement à
cloudy gaming un site de jeux vidéo
qu'elle ne connaît pas qu'elle n'a
jamais sollicité et surtout auquel elle
n'a jamais consenti pour vraiment j'ai
pas consenti à rien il demande rien il
dessine que tu es abonné décide
simplement
doit faire d'effort de dire je ne veux
pas être abonné à toi mais sinon tu es
abonné automatiquement donc j'aimerais
que vous lisiez ce texto là puis que
vous me disiez ce que vous en pensez à
Monsieur Trudaine
[Musique]
Pierre Trudel est professeur en droit du
cyberespace et du commerce électronique
à l'université de
montréalables
offrant et demandant le consommateur de
consentir il y a un problème il y a un
sérieux problème parce que évidemment
normalement on n'est pas abonné à un
service ou un bien
comme ça selon lui ce simple texto n'a
rien d'un consentement et n'est pas
conforme à la loi le consentement c'est
l'expression claire et sans équivoque
que la personne est d'accord pour
recevoir le bien pour recevoir le
service et évidemment pour payer ce qui
vient avec donc c'est pas l'inaction
qu'on devient consentant autrement dit
l'adage qui ne dit mot qu'on sent ça
marche pas dans le domaine du contrat en
scrutant ces factures Annick découvre
qu'elle paie pour cet abonnement depuis
trois mois il y a aucune explication de
tout ce qu'on voit
c'est ce il y a rien d'écrit peut-être
qu'on regarde ici dans le détail de de
ma facture à moi donc on voit que il y a
quelque chose au nom de pbm c'est avec
le montant encore presque 99
derrière
pbm.cx c'est la compagnie payby mobile
l'une des entreprises partenaires de
TELUS et de Kudos qui offre ce qu'on
appelle des applications tierces par
exemple un abonnement à des jeux vidéo
facturer directement sur le relevé de
cellulaire dans le fond eux permettent à
certains entreprises maintenant de
charger le client puis faciles dans le
fond de la facturation en mettant ses
frais d'or sur notre facture de
téléphone et moi c'est nouveau
partenaire de je suis pas du cliente à
eux chiante de coudeau c'est la seule
entreprise avec qui j'ai décidé de faire
affaire pour des autres j'ai pas choisi
Kudo à choisir ma place
Annick est loin d'être la seule à avoir
des problèmes avec des applications
tierces sur le site de Kudos et de TELUS
de nombreux clients se plaignent de ces
frais et ce depuis plus d'un an malgré
tout coup d’eau était le sans lavent les
mains et répondre que si vous pensez que
ces frais ne sont pas valides contactez
directement le fournisseur pour les
contester à force de ne rien faire à
force de prétendre que ça ne les
concerne pas
on finit par considérer que ils sont
complices
qui ont rapporté ça TELUS jamais rien
fait pour dire ok mais cette compagnie
là on arrête ça
malgré nos demandes répétées telus a
refusé de répondre à nos questions à la
caméra mais qui est ce partenaire dont
Annick se plaint sur le web on apprend
que le propriétaire de payby mobile et
PM Connect une compagnie basée en
Angleterre par courriel l'entreprise
nous écrit que les internautes cliquent
d'abord sur une publicité qui mène à une
page comme celle-ci ou le prix est
clairement affiché et que le
consentement nécessite une double
validation et que ce n'est que par la
suite que l'abonné reçoit un texto
pourtant nous avons présenté cette page
à quatre personnes qui ont dénoncé cette
situation à la facture toutes sont
formelles elles ne l'ont jamais vu
eux ils nous ont dit verbalement qu'il y
avait un double de consentement c'est
qu'il fallait commencer par cliquer sur
un lien moi c'est sûr que n'importe quel
lien qui aurait dit maintenant ça coûte
14 dollars de plus par mois je n'aurais
pas fait
questionner sur sa part de bénéfice sur
chaque abonnement telus a refusé de
répondre ce serait étonnant
effectivement qu'il fasse ça par charité
ce sont des entreprises commerciales
donc on peut présumer qu'il y a un
entendre par lequel il perçoivent une
partie des frais pour offrir ce service
aux applications tierces Annick a exigé
un remboursement auprès de PM Connect
mais on lui répond ne pas être en mesure
de le faire en raison des politiques de
koudos de son côté coup d’eau refuse de
bloquer ce type d'application sur les
quatre cellulaires de la famille ce qui
choque Annick ils nous ont dit qu'il
pouvait pas on est un peu à la merci de
des nouvelles façons de faire de coups
d’eau puis on a aucune façon de se
protéger de ça heureusement il existe un
organisme qui peut venir en aide à des
clients comme uniques la Commission des
plaintres relatives au service de
télécom télévision la CPRST nous sommes
ici afin d'aider les consommateurs nous
offrons un service de résolution d'un
plan qui est gratuit on est prêt de neuf
plainte sur 10 sont résolus José Bidal
Thibault est commissaire adjointe à la
CPST si les consommateurs font face à
des fraises inattendus sur leur facture
nous avons le pouvoir de vérifier si le
fournisseur de services a le droit de
leur facturer si l'abonné c'est inscrit
au service s'ils ont accepté de payer
les frais nous avons le pouvoir de
forcer les fournisseurs de services de
rembourser les consommateurs nous avons
aussi le pouvoir de leur forcer de
dédommager les consommateurs puis coup
de théâtre des lustres nous annonce qu'à
la suite d'un examen approfondi et la
constaté que certains fournisseurs ne
demandaient pas de consentement
explicite et a choisi de mettre fin à
leur relation avec eux TELUS n'a pas
voulu spécifier si PM Connect faisait
partie du nombre toutefois TELUS
confirme que leurs clients ne seront
plus facturés par PM Connect
de son côté PM Connect affirme que c'est
elle qui a mis fin à sa relation avec
Telus et qu'elle a des pratiques
responsables et conformes aux lois
canadiennes et québécoises finalement
quand il y a pas de véritables
surveillance réglementaires ils
entreprises réagissent pour gérer leur
image à peu près tout ce qu'il faut pour
Pierre Trudel la réglementation ne
protège pas suffisamment les
consommateurs
une sérieuse mise à niveau à faire pour
mettre en phase les lois qui protègent
les consommateurs avec ce que permet
désormais les technologies sauf qu'on
est vulnérable déjà qu'il y avait assez
de pièges comme ça mais tout d'un coup
des pièges il y a des compagnies avec
qui on a des contrats il va falloir que
quelqu'un intervienne pour dire ben
arrêtez
finalement Kudo a entièrement remboursé
à nexhicuan et à bloquer les entreprises
tierce sur son compte alors vous êtes
abonné Koodo ou TELUS vérifiez vos
factures et si nécessaire adressez-vous
au commissaire aux pleines relatif au
service de télécom et en passant
Vidéotron belle et Rogers ne permettent
pas ce genre de facturation